the jurogan experience if i didn't know
who you were
and i ran into you i would have no idea
that you're the same guy
it's crazy you're a [ __ ] completely
different human
yeah you went from this guy that looked
like you're really in bad shape to a guy
who looks like a guy on a void in jiu
jitsu
i'm like [ __ ] that guy let me get away
from him he's too big
you look [ __ ] great that's awesome
this is the greatest compliment i've
ever gotten
thank you very much by the way all i
want is to look like a big dude who's
not
just gigantic and fat that's all i want
dude you look like a gorilla you look
like a dangerous human being like how
did you do it
uh well over the past 20 years i've
gone back and forth with dieting i've
i've lost a [ __ ] little weight i've
gained a [ __ ] little weight back um
how did i do it i think that the the
thing that i've done that has been
sustainable is
undoing kind of look a lot of diets come
in and say just do this and you'll lose
weight
but we're not focused at all on how we
got to
whatever point we were at that we
considered non-optimal that we want to
change
and so undoing the bad habits that i had
that i would associate with allowing
myself to get up to 550 pounds
is really more important than anything
that i could say
this is what i did to lose weight does
that make sense yes
yes um so when did the process
start so you kind of went back and forth
but you've obviously been on a very
steady course
for how long now 20 years 19 years
2002 was the first time i
thought i really want to change my life
and i started then and how much weight
have you lost since then
2002 i went from 550 i did a liquid diet
for two months and lost
80 pounds that 80 pounds i've never
dipped back into
but so i was 450 and i went down to
close to just under 300 then went
back up to 400 then went down to 200
then back up to 350 and
for the past five years i've been around
the weight i'm at now so i've
i've really gotten that under control
and what are you at right now 270. that
is incredible
that is that's so incredible so
you've lost more than 200 pounds oh yeah
yeah i mean
solid i've lost 200 pounds a couple of
times
but you've also put on muscle like
you're a different
you're you're different all like you're
unrecognizable yeah i think
listen the other strange thing about
weight loss is
when you're building fat and you're
storing fat
your body is naturally building lean
tissue too just to support that fat so
under every obese person there's a
person with more than average muscle
um so because they have to carry around
all their weight yeah you're you're
naturally building muscle just by like
raising your heavier arm
yeah you say that to ralphie may because
ralphie may was so heavy and i was like
look at your legs dude
i go you'd be able to kick someone
through a [ __ ] wall if you just lost
weight yeah like is the
that just to be able to carry around i
have gnarly calves i bet you do dude
that's one of the few things that like i
i train sometimes with bodybuilders now
and my coach is a professional
bodybuilder george
jared feather shout out to him um and he
has a lot of
calf emphasis and i'm like i don't
really need to do that bro my cows are
good
yeah you carried around 500 pounds for
years yeah let's go to
can you show me a photo of ethan when he
was at his
heaviest so find me so has this affected
your
work because you know you were getting
roles
for so long as an actor when you were
large yeah
i think so yeah it has there was a time
if we go back to like 2015 um
and i had been really thin and when i
say really thin i mean 200 pounds but
for me that was
extraordinarily thin that's what i weigh
it which is crazy and you're a lot
bigger than me it's crazy to see
i looked i thought i looked um gaunt god
that since look at those two [ __ ]
pictures like
like if a girl broke up with you
when you were on the left and then ran
into you you know at the [ __ ] airport
when you were on the right i mean
that is bonkers man yeah it's incredible
yeah i mean truly truly incredible
that's my favorite picture and that's
not even down lighting
i i was an idiot and i'm not super
thrilled with my hair and my head and
i wouldn't shave my head because i
thought the hat looked better with a
little bit of hair poking out
and then it got in the way of down
lighting so that's not even as
good a picture as it could have downed
lighting that's what everybody wants for
abs yeah they want down lighting
yeah see the guns um so
your your training regimen must be like
pretty strict though look at that
[ __ ] picture that is so bananas dude
yeah what what movies i from remember
the titans wow
yeah that that that wasn't even the
heaviest that that's not the heavy i
mean i was probably
close to 500 there but no that's that's
not even the heaviest i i don't know
what to point to like
this picture down here is i believe
after remember the titans and i'm
certainly a little bit
heavier yeah wow
when you look at that and you know
how far you've come i mean it has to be
incredibly satisfying
it's incredibly satisfying but you know
look the reality is that um
i don't i i have
mental illness and i can't i don't look
at myself and think
like god i look great i i see nothing
but negative
stuff every day and i try to convince
myself i try to find something that i'm
happy with usually it's my traps i can
look at my traps because it's lean
there's not a bunch of loose skin
hanging there they're not all scarred up
from surgeries
and i look at my trap and i go like okay
that looks good and
based on that i can then start to feel
okay about myself
looking at those pictures you know
that's also a long time ago and i just
don't i cannot relate to how i lived
then
wow it it it's it's it's very bizarre
now when you say you have mental illness
meaning that
you're aware of this right so you're
aware you have a distorted perception of
yourself
yeah very much so and what it what do
you think is
what's fueling that distorted perception
i when i go back to like my childhood
i was put on a diet when i was five and
prior to that i had no sense of self
there
i existed and clearly i i had fun and i
played but i was not aware of my body as
a thing kind of if it is external to me
as a separate component to me or or just
as a thing itself
it just was and at five i was put on
this diet
and all these uh
parts of me were pointed out as being
super negative
and so i just at five years old yeah and
and i really and by the way
in fairness if you look at the average
five-year-old
today i i wasn't like i wasn't obese at
five
i was a chubby five-year-old but i was
super active
and i wasn't eating junk food all day
long and you're growing in your body too
yeah that's the thing about
five-year-olds it's like i've seen
kids that look kind of chubby and then
you run into them a few years later like
look at you you're a beanstalk
yeah yes i have four kids myself and and
you watch them they kind of go
in different directions wide and then
tall and
yeah there isn't a sad thing um
but i i spent most of my life feeling
wrong like literally that i was wrong or
bad or there was some
some just super negative about myself
and so i still have to fight through
that today catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience